[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les footballeurs bordelais maillot
sombre sont venus à Lyon avec
l'intention de continuer sur leur lancer
autrement dit de gagner une fois de plus
comme ils en ont l'habitude sur terrain
adverse sans doute n'aime-t-il pas le
mauvais temps puisque cette fois ils ont
fait un faux pas devant les Lyonnais les
Lyonnais qui au bout d'un quart d'heure
de jeu sur un centre de l'évier gauche
Rambert repris par dynalo ont marqué le
seul et unique but de la partie
malgré une série de contre-attaques très
incisives au cours de la deuxième
mi-temps les joueurs bordelais n'ont pas
pu refaire le handicap résultat il
perdent du terrain au classement du
championnat de France mais ils n'ont pas
perdu tout espoir de remporter le titre
Les Lyonnais d'ailleurs ont les mêmes
ambitions que
le système solaire est organisé et
chaque planète a un rôle à jouer autour
du Soleil la matière est organisée
chaque atome a un rôle bien déterminé à
jouer à l'intérieur de la molécule la
France doit être organisée car tout ne
doit pas dépendre de Paris la structure
urbaine de la France doit être revue car
à l'heure actuelle seuls quatre villes
dépassent 500 000 habitants
[Musique]
pour des raisons bien souvent
historiques on en trouve 6 en Italie
et 11 en Allemagne fédérale
le problème de l'aménagement du
territoire est un problème
d'organisation chaque ville doit avoir
un rôle défini à son échelle à côté de
Paris capitale à l'échelle mondiale il
faut créer deux villes d'importance
européenne
[Musique]
si métropole inter régional
vocation régionale plus une trentaine de
centres urbains
ces villes doivent attirer et garder les
étudiants et les élèves des grandes
écoles
les sièges sociaux des grandes
entreprises
ceux qui veulent se distraire en mettant
à leur disposition les installations
culturelles et sportives indispensables
et surtout ceux qui veulent trouver un
emploi
mais il ne suffit pas de revoir la
structure urbaine de la France si l'on
ignore le problème des grands réseaux de
communication centrée autour de la
capitale un habitant d'Angers se rend à
Dijon s'il veut avoir son rendez-vous
dans l'après-midi il devra faire 100 km
de plus et passer par Paris dont il ne
connaîtra que la navette interga
cette étoile devant Notre-Dame de Paris
et le point de départ des 14 national
les plus importants il faudra donc
moderniser les communications routières
comme à Tancarville créé de grands axes
transversaux aménager les voies
navigables comme le Grand Canal d'Alsace
[Musique]
pour suivre l'électrification des voies
ferrées
[Musique]
dans les grandes villes de province des
aérodromes pour assurer des relations
rapides
améliorer les liaisons internationales
comme il a été fait au Mont Blanc alors
pour eux dans 20 ans la France aura un
tout autre visage
[Musique]
Francis poulain qui est mort avec lui
disparaît un des plus grands musiciens
français de notre époque
le voici juste après la guerre au moment
où il composait la musique de figures
humaines sur un livret de Cocteau les
animaux modèles les mamelles de Tirésias
Stabat Mater autant d'oeuvres qui
témoignent de son talent et de sa
sensibilité
[Musique]
la vague de froid qui sévit sur l'Europe
n'a pas épargné la Hollande et le pays
des moulins et des tulipes a pris des
allures de Labrador du époque pour les
transporteurs auxquels le verglas a
rappelé parfois brutalement les lois
fondamentales de l'équilibre
[Musique]
à part les patineurs les seuls qui
bénéficient des rigueurs de l'hiver sont
les maraîchers en serre qui continuent
de faire pousser la laitue comme un
juillet une salade or mercuriale pour la
table de quelques privilégiés
au Japon l'hiver pose également des
problèmes à ceux qui doivent se déplacer
[Musique]
partir est une affaire de patience et
les trains aux horaires incertains
jouent bien malgré eux ou transsibériens
[Applaudissements]
nation industrielle avant tout le Japon
s'intéresse aux questions de rendement
[Musique]
quant à la fin des neiges par projection
d'eau chaude le remède s'est avéré pire
que le mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsqu'on février 62 France terminait
son premier voyage peu de gens se
doutaient que ce géant des mers n'avait
été au début que cette petite maquette
dont les formes avaient été étudiées et
modifiées plus de 30 fois au bassin des
carènes de Paris
dans son laboratoire qui se situe sur le
plan mondial parmi les plus grands les
essais sont effectués sur des modèles
réduits
dans un bassin long de 155 mètres la
maquette qui va être dirigée par
téléguidage et soumise à une houle qui
compte tenu des dimensions du modèle
réduit correspondrait dans la réalité à
un creux de 8 mai
[Musique]
toutes les réactions du bateau face au
tangage sont enregistrés sur les
appareils installés à bord
[Musique]
la maquette va maintenant subir ses
essais de roulis supportante en valeur
relative des vagues d'un creux de 6
mètres on peut juger de son comportement
par ce qui serait une forte houle
[Musique]
à la suite de ses premiers essais les
modifications nécessaires peuvent être
facilement faites sur les coques de ces
modèles qui sont constitués par un
moulage de cire et de paraffine les
dispositifs anti-roulis sont modifiés et
les rectifications de profil nécessité
par les interactions entre les hélices
et la carène sont effectués
[Musique]
les ateliers peuvent alors calculer
dessiner et fabriqués avec une précision
absolue les formes idéales de l'hélice
du futur navire sur des modèles d'un
diamètre de 20 à 30 cm
[Musique]
enfin les listes définitives et le
gouvernail sont mis en place
[Musique]
c'est dans ce bassin circulaire de 65
mètres de diamètre qui est la plus
grande des installations similaires
existantes dans le monde que se font les
essais de giration c'est ici qu'on
effectué leur dernier essai en modèle
réduit non seulement les bateaux
construits en France mais aussi se
construit dans de nombreux autres pays
grâce à ces modèles qui semblent naître
que des jouets les projets peuvent être
améliorés et les chantiers efficacement
conseillés
ainsi paquebot cargo pétrolier pourront
sillonner les mers aussi sûrement que ce
porte-avion qui lui aussi n'a été au
bassin des carêmes de Paris qu'une toute
petite maquette de scie
[Musique]
il y a l'art il y a la manière celle de
Claude viseuse sculpteur informel
l'amène à se rendre périodiquement dans
une fonderie de Saint-Ouen pour y jouer
avec du métal à 1200 degrés c'est ainsi
que s'épanouit l'inspiration créatrice
autrement dit que le sculpteur libéré
des contraintes du moulage entame
directement son dialogue poétique avec
le métal en fusion ainsi naissent des
formes des images silhouette
indéfinissable et pétrifiée que le
sculpteur a inventé dans l'instant il
les nomme concrètes
[Musique]
Eric Munster lui qui se veut peintre a
une manière disons expéditive de
concevoir l'élaboration de son œuvre ses
instruments des sacs en plastique
remplis de peinture et d'un mélange des
tanins
une allumette
et
tout ceci n'est évidemment pas sans
risque c'est pourquoi Munster au père de
préférence sur les quais de la Seine
[Musique]
voilà il affirme ainsi vouloir faire de
l'art mais on ne peut s'empêcher de le
soupçonner de vouloir d'abord faire du
bruit
cela fait aussi des trous mais comme le
dit l'artiste les trous aussi ça se vend
[Musique]